an ambitious idea that spent most of a
decade in a cycle of living and dying
might have reset the clock on itself for
the last time here's why the edge of
tomorrow's sequel may be buried in the
rubble of yesterday
while speaking with MTV News in 2015 Tom
Cruise revealed that he had pitched an
idea for an edge of tomorrow's sequel to
director Doug Lyman and co-writer
Christopher macquarrie though the star
didn't reveal any details Crews
confirmed that blunts would be
interested in joining the projects the
following year a few months after Cruz's
comments Macquarie confirmed to collider
that the creative team had the idea for
the sequel ready to go ideas turned into
words as 2016 brought the news that race
writers Joe shrapnell and Anna
Waterhouse will be Penning the sequel
with deadline reporting that Macquarie
would join as producer and script
consultant by the end of 2016 Lyman had
signed on as director and revealed to
collider that the upcoming c chord be a
prequel it's unclear if that was the
idea Cruz originally had pitched Lyman
however was completely enthralled by the
idea of returning to the world of Edge
of Tomorrow telling IGN I have these
intellectual ideas on how you should
make a sequel that's unlike how anybody
else makes a sequel and this gripped and
this idea fit perfectly into that idea
so it's going to revolutionize how
people make sequels with such high
expectations one would assume that
cameras would begin rolling as soon as
possible but Cruz instead went on to
focus on Mission Impossible Fallout
stalling momentum as 2018 came around it
was confirmed that the sequel would be
titled Live Die repeats and repeat with
Lyman enthusiastically telling collider
that he blunt and Cruz were passionate
about the sequel he also confirms that
previous scheduling issues between the
trio had been worked out
while Doug Lyman at hopes to film The
Edge of tomorrow's sequel after chaos
walking the film is still in
pre-production will Live Die Repeat and
repeats ever come out it seems unlikely
a few short months after Lyman expressed
enthusiasm about Tom Cruise and Emily
Blunt returning the director revealed
that a new script was being written by
Jazz Butterworth who co-wrote the
original film via collider later the
invention of line writer Matthew
Robinson was courted in 2019 to rewrite
the script The Hollywood Reporter
confirmed while the live die repeats and
repeat script as Changing Hands blunt
revealed to Indy wire that Cruz wanted
the sequel to film in 2017. the actress
declined as she had already signed on as
a titular character in Mary Poppins
returns blunt did however confirm that
she was interested in returning and was
hoped for that Lyman would produce a
quality script and the director did
confirming in 2019 that the script was
ready putting the ball in cruise and
Blunt's Court via comic book movie in
2021 Lyman told collider that the script
was still all being worked on but that
it wasn't a good State revealing that it
didn't matter how far along the script
was he said if you can get Tom Cruise
and Emily Blunt to commit to the movie
it's going to happen with Christopher
Macquarie and a wide variety of other
writers working on the project changing
its Vision it's easy to see why Cruz and
blunt didn't commit early on in the
writing process can't stand the sight of
blood not so much as a paper cut
ask Emily Blunt that she'll say to the
proposed sequel has too large a price
tag speaking to Howard Stern in 2021 the
actress said that she can't imagine how
the film would be made in a post-covered
world honestly I think the movie's too
expensive following the rising costs of
goods and supply chain issues for Key
Products Hollywood has been actively
trying to lower production costs
according to the Hollywood Reporter
Luntz said I don't know how we're going
to do it and I think that it's hard to
align everyone's schedules I think until
we figure out what's going on with the
industry we need to figure out what is
the next road map for the kinds of films
that people want to make Warner Brothers
the studio behind Edge of Tomorrow has
seen his fair share of difficulties in
recent years casting doubts on their
ability to bankroll a lessons your
project after a t exited the company the
entertainment Giants hold 47.5 billion
dollars in net debt according to Insider
intelligence making it crucial that the
next few years feature a string of hits
even if Cruise Lunds and Lyman could
align their schedules it doesn't look
like Warner Brothers is in the position
to Pony up the 100 million dollars plus
the edge of tomorrow's sequel with
demand however fans of the franchise
shouldn't lose hope as has a possibility
that a series could hit HBO Max in the
coming years you're not going to believe
what I'm about to tell you no I'm not
Warner Brothers made the shocking choice
in 2021 to send this entire theatrical
slate to his newly launched streaming
HBO Max Village Roadshow a frequent
co-financer of Warner Brothers sued the
media giant for a breach of contract by
sending the Matrix resurrections to HBO
Max according to the guardian made
publicly available in 2022 the court
documents of the lawsuit revealed that
Edge of Tomorrow another property that
Village Roadshow had its hands in
developing is on track to receive the
HBO Max treatment the contents of the
document don't suggest what state the
developments the edge of tomorrow's
series is in or if it will feature Tom
Cruise and Emily Blunt no creatives like
Doug Lyman or Christopher macquarrie are
publicly attached as of now recent years
have seen several successful films be
adapted for television like Let the
Right One In and Cobra Kai so it's not
too surprising to see the potential
Warner Brothers season adapting the
Sci-Fi Action flick for the small screen
the series could potentially retell the
events of the original film and
implements lyman's idea for a sequel for
a second season or it could go in a
different direction focusing on another
military member getting stuck in a Time
Loop anything is possible especially if
the series hits HBO Max which has proven
itself as one of the best streaming
services as for where the sequel
currently stands who knows only time
will tell if Edge of Tomorrow is
destined to get a sequel or if the HBO
Max series will manifest
[Music]